The American flag baseball's my favorite sport here at sport Diesel's my favorite sport also known as the Stars and Stripes
our Lord and Savior excellent now for something new
This is a national holiday called Thanksgiving on the fourth Thursday of every November families feast and
Think about what they're thankful for which one's said daddy
Do I have a daddy
Of course you do, Dr. Vogelbaum filling
Does that mean you're my mommy
Sure, I
Can be your mommy
So you love me I do
And you'll always take care of me always
It's okay, we'll take care of her just like the others
Today we had another incident
But this time this subject was not driven by anger, but by something else altogether I
Told dr. Vogel Baum that the subject was obviously suffering from isolation adduce depression
But he didn't respond
He just told me to find another tutor
What we didn't tell you
I'm your father we our family
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie. This is gonna be my new video for the boys season two teaser trailer
they just dropped a little while ago to preview the new season in a breakdown of the new storm front villain that we got our
First look at if you haven't read the comic books
Obviously the boys is based on Garth Ennis comic book series storm front is one of the worst
Villains in the series just as bad if not worse than homeland. Er, so we'll break it down
We're doing an Amazon giveaway
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave your favorite moment from the boys on the video
addressing the footage during the trailer first
You see home Lander as a child getting
indoctrinated and it seems kind of like they're
Brainwashing him which I like the way they play with that because it makes sense why he's so crazy in present day
He's so isolated from other people
He never really had anyone that he treated like a mother and even though Vogel bomb was effectively his father
He only viewed him through glass at most times like when he's a baby before he learns to control his powers
You see all these scorch marks all over the place. Like he accidentally a bunch of people
diabolical and even when his middle school age during a lot of this clip
It seems like he's knowingly a lot of these people like, oh, they'll just clean up the mess
I can do whatever I want
Well on the road to becoming the full-blown
Psychopath that he is in present day and more to the villains that they're introducing during season two
There's a whole bunch of new characters
But storm front is every bit the psychopath homeland er is and in the comics homeland
Er is actually a derivative of storm land a lot of the genetic engineering that went into building
Homeland ER so to speak because he was genetically engineered came from stuff that they studied using storm front
But then you had the tag at the end with him meeting his son
the sort of super boy or twisted version of super boy now that we have on the TV show in
Butchers former wife or still wife technically, they didn't get divorced. So there's a whole lot going on here. Obviously homeland
ER is trying to get butcher to back off
You hate me for a reason that you shouldn't hate me because your wife clearly cheated on you with
Me and this baby was the product. I think the twist though is is the butcher's gonna spin that on his head and try to
Use his son against him
Because they've already changed so much of the comic-book plot and part of the idea of homeland
ER is that he's almost unkillable not completely unkillable, but the idea is is there's no other superhero
That's quite as powerful as him in the world. He is the top
He's sort of like their version of the century
If you're a big Marvel comic book fan someone who is so crazy powerful
but just a little
deranged
just in terms of power levels Queen Maeve they introduced this season obviously had a relationship with homeland err for a little while even though
They couldn't stand each other
She's so much more powerful than the other members of the seven except for homeland, er, she's not nearly as powerful as he is
So she's like the next best option if you want a deterrent to take home Lander down but so is storm front super powerful
But not quite as powerful as home Lander
But if you're not a big comic book reader storm front as the name implies is meant to be a parody of Marvel's Thor
But also DC's Shazam, he can fly he has lightning based powers, but his origin is just as twisted as home Landers
If not more twisted so home Lander was actually genetically engineered in the United States in present-day
The timeline of the boys is a little bit different in the comics
It takes place a little bit further back in history the whole idea of Vaud american using compound v to create superheroes
Started way back with german research during world war ii Vogel bomb used to be a scientist
He created Stormfront and created compound B, but through Operation Paperclip
a lot of those German scientists wound up living in the United States under new identities in
Vogel bomb wound up working for Vaud America and creating superheroes for them using compound B. So comic book Stormfront was a full-blown
He really loved what they were doing and he was all about it. But because he's a superhero
He doesn't age the way that normal people do so the way that Vaud american spins these fake backstories about the heroes
they say that Stormfront is actually a
Reincarnated viking when really he was actually born during World War two
The version of the character that the show is going with is gonna be played by I Akash from you're the worst
This is what she looks like in costume with full makeup. Her costume looks pretty close to storm fronts comic book costume
obviously
they toned it down because his physique is so
Huge but it's the same deal with homeland her homeland her on the TV show is a little bit slimmer than comic book homeland
Er the way, the showrunner talked about her character made it sound like they might be tweaking her backstory a little bit
She might not originate from World War two
But they did say that they would be going with a lot of the themes of the storm front character
So they claim she'll be a more modern-day spin on what?
might be like or someone who used to be a back during World War two and is still pretty rotten in present-day
But they said that she would be rotten to her soul. Just like comic-book Stormfront
What a coincidence that the actress just came from a TV show called you're the worst because Stormfront is definitely one of the worst
Quote-unquote supers the first time you meet the character in the comics in a really big way. You're actually getting backstory from tech knight
Who's sort of a combination of Batman and Iron Man in the comics in this really really twisted backstory?
I don't know what they're gonna do tech night. They haven't announced it, but they did say that they be doing payback
So I'm assuming the tech night will show up at some point. I know a lot of you comic book fans
We're asking about him on my earlier boys videos
He's got this weird brain tumor that causes him to want to have sex with objects and just pretty much anything
Uncontrollably and it becomes this weakness that Billy butcher from the boys winds up
Exploiting trying to turn him into an informant part of the beauty of the butcher character
Is that even though he doesn't have any superpowers he's able to beat these supers with?
information and he's able to turn them to his site into
Informants so he can find out about the weaknesses and plans and goings-on of other teams when he's trying to take them down
His real superpower winds up being information
early speculation about her backstory on the TV show what they might do if they don't want to go for the world war ii
Germany origin story, they might just say that she was also created around the same time that homeland
Ur was created in wound up being almost as successful
You have to imagine this storm front even though she's not quite as powerful as home lander is still head-and-shoulders
Way more powerful than any other superhero on planet earth
But comic book storm front was meant to be the real world's first superhero
And we've all been joking about the hero gasm for you comic book readers out
There hero gazon is an arc in the comics where billy butcher and the boys try to go
Exploit some of the supers while they're at a retreat called the hero gasm which is exactly what it sounds like
All the supers trying to get with each other in the nastiest possible way
They were joking about it during their press junkets for season 1 at Comic Con this past summer like oh, yeah
We're gonna try and do it at some point season 2 and people are like no way
There's no way you can get away with doing something that crazy on TV for them
It winds up being a challenge because Amazon gave them so much more money for season 2
So that's why we're getting so many more characters while they're doing
Payback team while we're getting storm front and all the other characters
The reason why I'm saying confirmed payback is because the crimson countess is gonna be a character during season two
You see this poster that they showed from behind the scenes
She was a character that belonged to the payback team as you can probably tell even if you're not a comic book reader
She's meant to be a parody of Marvel Scarlet Witch
they've been a lot of people that have theorized about
Endgame being different from the comic book version of endgame because this is very clear arc that homeland er has and even though he's kind
Of set up as the main villain of the comic series right now
Technically, he's not the worst character in the story
So we might see more of that in the background during season two
but they haven't said how many seasons they're planning on going and I still feel like the TV show because it's changing so much of
The comics is really gonna lean heavy into this Superboy's son that he has now. He's not something from the comic book
That's totally original to the TV show
So I think the whole idea that homeland er is now in love with the idea of being a dad
Oh, wow, I can give this kid the father that I never had but no surprise
He probably winds up being a pretty terrible father in the Sun might wind up hating him by the end of the series. No
Thanks to butcher probably trying to use his son against him just early speculation
I just feel like butcher is gonna try and use his son as a weapon against home Lantern knowing that there's nothing on earth that
Can really take down homeland or at least that he knows about right now
They also just cast patton oswalt in a super-secret
Role and I'm wondering if he might be playing the legend because they didn't do the legend during season one and he's a pretty big
Character on the boys. He's meant to be a parody of Stan Lee in real life
He's even kind of drawn to look like a Stan Lee type figure not someone with actual superpowers
But an information broker that has information in secrets on all the superheroes
so a lot of times when butcher needs specific information about weaknesses that
Superheroes have or where they're going to be or what they're doing
He goes to the legend to get that everyone post all your predictions for
Stormfront and homeland err during season two and let me know if there's any boys
videos that you guys want me to make if there's any big questions you guys have or videos about specific characters or
Storylines they finished filming next week
So we might get some more footage or promo of some sort before the end of the year
And I'm hoping that they premiere sometime by next summer
But they haven't confirmed when they're actually planning on releasing season 2
While you wait for everything click here for my video on the boys season 1
Click here for that brand new Star Wars Episode nine rise of Skywalker trailer in Easter eggs. Thank you so much for watching
Everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight